this episode has been supported by
lambda labs dear fellow scholars this is
two minute papers with károly on alpha
here in our earlier paper Gaussian
material synthesis we made a new
renderer and what this neural renderer
was able to do is reproduce the results
of a light transport simulation within
four to six milliseconds in a way that
is almost pixel perfect it took a fixed
camera and scene and we were able to
come up with a ton of different
materials and it was always able to
guess what the output would look like if
we change the physical properties of a
material this is a perfect setup for
material synthesis where these
restrictions are not too limiting trying
to perform high-quality neural rendering
has been a really important research
problem lately and everyone is asking
the question can we do more with this
can we move around with the camera and
have a neural network predict what the
scene would look like can we do this
with animations well have a look at this
new paper which is a collaboration
between researchers at the Technical
University of Munich and Stanford
University where all we need is some
video footage of a person or object it
takes a close look at this kind of
information and can offer three killer
applications one it can synthesize the
object from new viewpoints
- it can create a video of the scene and
imagine what it would look like if we
reorganized it or can even add more
objects to it
you
and three perhaps everyone's favorite
performing facial reenactment from a
source to a target actor as with many
other methods these neural textures are
stored on top of the 3d objects however
a more detailed high dimensional
description is also stored and learned
by this algorithm which enables it to
have a deeper understanding of intricate
light transport effects to create these
new views for instance it is
particularly good at reproducing
specular highlights which typically
change rapidly as we change our
viewpoint for the object one of the main
challenges was building a learning
algorithm that can deal with this kind
of complexity the synthesis of mouth
movements was always the Achilles heel
of these methods so have a look at how
well this one does with it you can also
see with the comparisons here that in
general this new technique smokes the
competition so how much training data do
we need to achieve this I would imagine
that this would take hours and hours of
video footage right no not at all this
is what the results look like as a
function of the amount of training data
on the left you see that it already kind
of works with 125 images but contains
artifacts but if we can supply a
thousand images we're good note that a
thousand images sounds like a lot but it
really isn't it's just half a minute
worth of video how crazy is that
imitation still apply you see one
failure case here and the neural network
typically needs to be retrained if we
wish to use it on new objects but this
work finally generalizes to multiple
viewpoints animation scene editing lots
of different materials and geometries
and I can only imagine what we'll get to
more papers down the line respect to
used tools for accomplishing this and in
general make sure to have a look at
Matias nice noise lab who just got
tenured as a full professor and he's
only 32 years old congratulations if you
have a are related ideas and you would
like to try them but not do it in the
cloud because you wish to own your own
hardware look no further than lambda
labs lambda labs offers sleek
beautifully designed laptops
workstations and servers that come
pre-installed with every major learning
framework and updates them for you
taking care of all the dependencies look
at those beautiful and powerful machines
this way you can spend more of your time
with your ideas and don't have to deal
with all the software maintenance work
make sure to go to lambda labs comm
slash papers or click their link in the
video description and look around and if
you have any questions you can even call
them for advice big thanks to lambda
labs for supporting this video and
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time